le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
les Seychelles destinations réputée pour
ses plages paradisiaques
son eau turquoise ces paysages de cartes
postales qui ne rêve pas d'y passer
quelques jours pour profiter de tous ses
atouts mais la vie aux Seychelles et
coûteuse et le tourisme de l'archipel
était essentiellement un tourisme de
luxe
c'est donc plutôt difficile de pouvoir
un jour envisager ses vacances
et pourtant quelques réunionnais issues
de milieux modestes vivent aux
Seychelles ayant trouvé un emploi
comment ont-ils organiser leur voyage
comment ont-ils trouver un travail dans
ce pays qui n'est pas francophone on en
parle maintenant dans le lien social
Didier à 31 ans il exerce le métier de
boulanger pâtissier poussé par l'envie
de découvrir d'autres horizons il a un
jour décidé de tenter sa chance hors
départements
malgré les obstacles administratifs
Didier a choisi de partir aux Seychelles
un archipel réputé dans le monde entier
pour la qualité de ses plages et de ses
hôtels de luxe
actuellement Didier travaille dans un
hôtel 5 étoiles aux Seychelles non
seulement il approfondit ses
connaissances car il est encadré par un
grand chef pâtissier mais il profite
aussi dans ces moments libres de tout ce
que peut lui offrir cette région
magnifique
avant de venir si je travaillais dans le
milieu d'un menuiserie
il travaille pendant 4 à 5 ans comme
j'ai un diplôme de boulanger vous voulez
venir ici pour pouvoir travailler dans
la boulangerie pâtisserie d'un grand
hôtel pour avoir des expériences et pour
pouvoir retourner en réunion pour
pouvoir partager ça ici mon contraste un
CDD de 12 mois et comme cela fait que
deux marches ici je me suis pas encore
projeté dans le futur je vais attendre
un peu dans trois quatre mois pour
savoir vraiment ce que je vais faire
la Réunion me manque aussi par rapport à
mes amis ma famille mais je suis très
content d'être ici de pouvoir vivre
cette expérience donc Norma aidé à
trouver le thème aussi au financement de
mon billet d'avion et d'une aide à
l'arrivée d'une valeur de 300 euros
même aux Seychelles il nous faut un visa
et c'est un visa travail donc de
moi-même je veux pas pu le faire la vie
ici va être très simple
il y a de super paysages il fait super
beau tout le temps mettant libre j'ai
passé à plat à la pêche des fois on va
pouvoir courir et aussi voir les tortues
grâce à l'aide du CNRM Didier s'épanouit
dans sa vie professionnelle et
personnelle il a pu bénéficier d'un
suivi sérieux et efficace pour lui
permettre d'obtenir tous les documents
nécessaires car travailler à l'étranger
ça n'est pas simple administrativement
Armande revient des Seychelles elle y a
exercé la fonction d'assistant éducatif
de la langue française c'est en 2008 que
j'ai eu l'occasion grâce au département
de me rendre aux Seychelles pour
travailler travailler dans l'éducation
et je dois vous dire que ce fut une
expérience extraordinaire tant sur le
plan professionnel que sur le plan
humain je me suis fait des amis je garde
encore contact avec eux et lors de mon
retour je n'ai eu aucun mal à m'insérer
à trouver à trouver un travail je compte
renouveler cette expérience également
dans un dans une autre destination
le cnharm met tout en oeuvre pour
permettre aux Réunionnais de tenter leur
chance hors départements un service à
l'écoute et efficace un processus
sérieux à la disposition des Réunionnais
notre expérience que mobilité sur les
Seychelles se envisage à deux niveaux
d'abord au niveau des assistants
éducatifs de langue française
l'expérience qui a démarré déjà deux
années et plus récemment nous avons
envoyé 14 réunionnais dans un groupe
hôtelier international à 5 étoiles pour
travailler dans un hôtel dans les
différentes tâches à une fonction qu'il
y a dans des grands groupes hôteliers et
nous sommes de plus en plus partisans de
l'envoi en mobilité de Réunionnais dans
les îles avoisinantes pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est moins loin c'est un
contexte insulaire qui connaisse et
deuxième raison nous aurons en ce sens
pour une vraie coopération régionale
avec les îles avoisinantes et nous
sommes conformes à cette poétique de
coopération régionale qui nous paraît
importante pour la réunion concernant
donc effectivement le gouvernement c'est
chez loi il est très ouvert sur la
coopération avec avec la France et donc
à travers elle avec la Réunion d'abord
pour regarder présente la francophonie
donc la langue française dans leurs îles
et deuxièmement parce qu'ils sont
conscients que nous avons une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée dans des domaines oui
ou pas de main d'oeuvre notamment le
domaine hôtelier puisqu'il y a beaucoup
de madoffs importés qui me permettait
cette expression en Seychelles et donc
travailler avec la Réunion et quelque
chose de pratique et de voulu par le
gouvernement c'est chez loi nous sommes
vraiment dans une volonté politique
forte et tout à fait positive
grâce à l'aide du cnharm Didier et
d'autres réunionnais tentent leur chance
en métropole et dans d'autres pays une
volonté d'essayer de vivre autrement sur
le plan professionnel et personnel un
choix de vie soutenu par le département
qui penser aux Réunionnais ou qu'il soit
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais